how does it feel to be here tonight for
the British Independent Film Wars it's
good is good yeah it's weird with all
the lights and all the fancy stars
I don't wanna be but yeah I'm just
really happy with the film you know
continues to get more more momentum with
awards and reviews and all these things
that I think I really think the film
deserves it you know when you were
making my brother's a double what kind
of feeling did you have about it did you
see it going as far as it's gone already
no I mean I'm always amazed that a movie
even gets made in the UK you know we
don't have much of a film industry here
it's very small very intimate so when
one gets made and it's really really
great and it's much bigger than what you
would expect it to be then it's kind of
an anomaly so it's really the little
train that could this film you know it's
amazing but it's gonna get a release in
America and it's won awards at Sundance
battalion it's amazing and that's all
testament to Sally really Sally Allah
say me I mean I think she's a very very
special filmmaking talent very unique
tell me a little bit about how you
prepared for your role yeah well I had
basically five six months while the film
got greenlit I'm not really that that
character you know I'm not a gangster
I'm not Arab I'm not from that world so
I I had so basically I guess for lack of
a better term go method and sadly had
some really good contacts in the world
that the movies inspired by so I
actually spent a lot of time in Dorset
in Hackney with the real guys and in
some real games and just absorbed really
there kind of being in the nature and
got to know them really and yeah it's
it's it sounds very difficult but it's
not actually if you're lucky enough to
have enough time to do it you find that
you naturally can mimic and understand
people if you spend a lot of time you
apt the are a natural mimic cuz also
you've been playing Freddie Mercury
having new kind of embodying him how was
that that was crazy I mean it was it was
in his film for BBC and I'm a huge
Freddie might be fans I was a bit
daunting really
yeah I don't know what to say about it I
mean Freddie's Freddie he's an icon and
it's it's it's strange playing I didn't
realize I looked like him but apparently
I do with him a star and but no he's
some yeah I love him so it was nice to
play someone that you really adore but
also quite frightening and it seems to
go well what else you up to at the
moment I've got a couple movies I'm
doing ones independent film British
Independent Film you're here about soon
next year and then also I'm going to be
promoting my brother the devil around
March for its release in America which
is quite a big deal I can't
unfortunately because it's I'm attached
as a lead but they obviously it's
pending dates and finance and things but
very different from my brother the devil
yeah very very different yeah I don't
want to repeat myself you know who James
my goodness this is looking good Martin
si you suit it you really do how's it
feeling um overwhelming emotional I'm
not sure I should talk right now because
I feel you know I mean I'm just happy
that the film has got more recognition I
hope with this award and continues to be
seen by many many people because I feel
that I really feel that my brother the
devil is extremely important and
wonderful tell me a little bit about why
you think it's so important well
basically you know we there are so many
first times in this films one of the
first times that we've had two British
Arab characters portrayed on screen and
a very complex three-dimensional light
and then also I think it it's an urban
film it's not really an urban film has
vulnerability and sensitivity that we've
never really seen I think it's very
important and great to have such a young
cast as well as doing so well tell me a
little bit about working with your other
co-stars great yeah I mean the
performances a phenomenal across the
border that's all because of Sally
al-husseini in hereditary in kitchen but
obviously the actors as well and I think
work with the tissue right and Anthony
Welsh is brilliant bachchi a man how do
Chi
SciTech now he's not a young actor
at two in particular fatty Elsayed who
plays my younger brother who I think has
given one of the most phenomenal daily
performances I've ever seen
you